[Music]
Thank You William and thank you all very
much for allowing me to address you
today your annual meeting which I hear
was changed specifically to accommodate
me so I do apologize for your Diaries
I'm especially pleased to do so as
supporting charities is the heart of
what I and the whole royal family do
that said as most of you will appreciate
no one not even me says no to William
Shawcross so I have no choice anyway so
I thought I start with something
personal a tribute to my parents I have
two children as you probably know I
gather it has been widely reported and
when I first became a father four and a
half years ago I began to process of
thinking about the way I'd been brought
up and the values that my parents are
they're still than me as any parent will
know this process is not necessarily one
that you want to take consciously you
find the certain values ones that you
didn't know you had to start bubbling up
to the surface some Wireless memories
relates times my parents spoke to me or
even better
showed me what it meant to have both
privilege and responsibilities
I remember being taken by my mother to a
homelessness shelter at a young age her
explaining to me why the people I met
there matter and why no society can be
healthy unless we take other people
seriously for my father I learned how
central charity was or how central China
was to his life and his sense of purpose
the Prince's Trust is not an
arm's-length organization for my father
he cares deeply about the princess trust
because it is a living projection of his
values as a young child I recall evening
after evening my father's diligence and
compassion as he applied himself to
answering thousands of letters and
reading endless reports in order to stay
on top of his ambition to do all he
could to help the underprivileged
without my realizing it's what my
parents were doing was distilling in me
and Harry a lifelong habits to put
charity at the heart of our lives my
father of course had inherited this very
same habit from his parents
my grandfather Prince Phillip has been
one of the most tireless public servants
of this country deeply committed to
helping young people fulfill their
potential my grandmother the Queen has
never given a Christmas broadcast
without paying tribute to charitable
organisations volunteers and people who
care for others my family have not done
this because it looks good they do
because charity is not an optional extra
in society we believe that above
anything else charities nurture repair
build and sustain our society
[Music]
you